Welcome. Welcome to the Tonight
Show everybody. You're here.
You made it. Thank you for
watching.
The weather right now is crazy.
Uh a state of emergency has
been declared here in New York
as a massive northeaster slams
the East Coast with heavy rain,
flooding, and intense winds.
Yep, we're in a state of
emergency or as Facebook calls
it Tuesday. Uh seriously, it's
gross out there. Right now, the
entire East Coast smells like
damp mask.
Yeah, we're dealing with that
intense wind where they your
mask blows off of your face and
lands on to someone else's.
Wait on Baxter, are you vaxed?
Here in New York City, the
streets are so flooded, all the
shrimp and bubblegum made a
break for the Hudson. Let's go
boys. Yeah. That's right.
Already thousands have lost
power making it the one time
people actually turned on their
iPhone flashlights on purpose.
It's like oh that's what it's
for. Let's get to some news. Of
course everyone's been talking
about Facebook lately and Mark
Zuckerberg just announced that
he's retooling the social media
platform towards young adults
and away from older users.
Honestly just make it a little
harder to sign in and you'll
never see an old person on
Facebook. How many stop signs?
Scan my face. And my aunt's
gonna have a lot of free time
if she can't use Facebook to
write love this under every
inspirational quote. You're
really inspired today. Wow.
Meanwhile today executives from
TikTok and Snapchat testified
before a senate panel for the
first time. Usually the only
TikTok on Capitol Hill is
coming from a senator's
pacemaker. It's not ticking
anymore. You better. There, now
it's working. Yeah, it was
hours of tech executives trying
to explain their apps to
senators. Experts are calling
it a preview of your family at
Thanksgiving. So, how do I get
to the Snapchat? Yup, senators
believe social media is
corrupting our teens and they
might be on to something cuz a
bunch of 15 year olds barged in
for a lick a senator challenge.
Take his flag pin and throw a
baloney at him.
That's a challenge. That's a
challenge. Of course. Wet mask.
Yeah. Some more news from
Washington. Uh President Biden
is still negotiating his new
spending bill with Congress and
hopes to have a deal by the end
of this week. Biden's bill
started at $3. 5 trillion and
now it's down to about 2
trillion. Right now he's like a
guy at the airport taking stuff
out of his bag to get under 50
pounds. He's like I don't think
I need shirts right? How much
are we to wear shirts right? I
guess I can wear my skew boots
on the plane. The deal's
getting held up cuz senators
Joe Manchin and Kirsten Cinema
keep adding stipulations. It's
getting nuts. Right now they
won't sign the bill until Kyrie
Irving is allowed to play for
the Nets. Some business news
Hertz just announced that it's
buying 100, 000 Teslas for its
fleet of rental cars then to
give Hertz a taste of their own
medicine Tesla said sorry we
don't have any Teslas right now
is it Kia Rio okay
Oh we have sorry. And with this
rental you keep this car. It's
your problem. I mean your car
now. Hey I read about a man in
Georgia who's facing federal
charges after he spent over
$57, 000 in COVID relief funds
on a single Pokemon card. Wow,
his wife would be so
embarrassed if she existed.
It's
It's gonna be rough when he
gets to prison and explains
he's there cuz he loves
Squirtle. You know what I'm
saying? Ho ho hey guys get this
I heard about a guy who bought
a Six Flags annual pass how
about this deal you get the Six
Flags annual pass right it
allows you to get unlimited
food for 150 bucks. he's eaten
nearly all of his meals at Six
Flags ever since Of course, all
the money he saved is now going
to doctors to get his
cholesterol down from $1, 000
And finally, a man in Lithuania
broke a world record by sitting
up to his neck in a container
of ice for three hours. Then he
stood up and broke the record
for most disappointed
girlfriend. Here's some good
news. Last night an FDA panel
gave the green light to the
Pfizer vaccine for kids between
the ages of five and 11. That's
right.
That's right. Kids vaccines are
the best way to prevent the two
things parents fear the most,
COVID and homeschooling. I
don't know, three goes into
five. I don't know, not about
two. Yep, this is great. In a
few weeks, you're gonna see
bouncers outside Chuck E.
Cheese checking vaccine cars.
Not today, Timmy. Sorry. Kids
can get the shot as soon as
next week? Great timing, right?
After they go door to door on
Halloween. Wanna move it up
three days? Who's talking to
who here? Here's how the
vaccine will work. Older kids
can get Pfizer, younger kids
can get Moderna, and the middle
child can get Johnson and
Johnson.
Pretty soon you're gonna see a
vaccine centered parking lot
with white tents, orange cones
waving in little toy jeeps.
Some parents said that they
aren't sure if they're
comfortable giving their kids
the vaccine. Then they went
back to feeding them dunkaroos
for breakfast.
There's someone else's problem
for the next six hours. Go and
do it. Some news from
Washington this morning. Senate
Democrats rolled out a new tax
proposal that would only target
the 700 richest Americans as a
way to help Biden's spending
plan. So that includes Elon
Musk, Jeff Bezos, and Flo the
Progressive Insurance Lane.
It's tough for billionaires. If
you'd like to sponsor 1, you
can make a difference for just
$34 million dollars a day. Just
text billions to 01528. You
know cash is tight for
billionaires when their flights
in space had the layover in
Cleveland. But by this
afternoon Democrats scrap the
tax on billionaires and now
they might tax millionaires
instead. Yep. When they heard
that Kim and Kylie were like
yes well Khloe, Courtney, and
Kendall were like no. Well Iowa
Senator Chuck Grassley who is
88 recently announced that he
is running for re-election in
2022. And while a lot of
critics say that he's too old
and should retire, I think he
still got it. Just watch this
clip from today. I
when you don't hold your own
accountable. Let's not forget
about Obama Biden
administration
This is not a good sign when
your staff is nearby with a set
of jumper cables, you know? Ray
goes on right nipple? When an
aide said senator are you
alright? He was like there's a
senator here. No, but
What are you doing? I think the
whole world just need to take
the weekend. Yeah. Tomorrow's
the weekend. Just take the
weekend. We'll come back
Monday. We'll figure it all
out. Oh. Uh some movie news.
Today, Pixar released the first
trailer for their Buzz
Lightyear origin story. Yeah, a
Buzz Lightyear prequel. It's
about how he first goes to
space as a publicity son for
Jeff Bezos. But the prequel
looks interesting. For
instance, I had no idea that
when Buzz's family arrived at
Ellis Island, they changed
their name from Light Uranelli.
Really?
Light Urinelli. Yeah. Do you
guys see this? There's a new
dating show in the UK and it's
kind of similar to the bastard
but there's a there's one big
difference. Just take a look at
this. David, Who do you think
is a love trap.
Sure.
It got awkward when he was
like, wait, I meant Becca. I'm
sorry. Yeah, it's just like the
bachelor but instead of being
escorted out in a limo, they
were taken away in an
ambulance. Some more
entertainment news I read that
Netflix is looking to build a
new TV and film production
studio in New Jersey yeah and
apparently Netflix is even
coming out with some New Jersey
themed TV shows really yeah
I'll show you what I mean first
up there's Bridge and Tunnelton
oh next there's Squid Game just
the tracksuits Next up, instead
of the show you, there's yous.
And finally there's oh
No, he like that.
Well, some business news, the
outdoor clothing company
Patagonia just introduced its
own collection of natural wine.
Finally, answering the
question, what is the whitest
sentence you've ever heard?
How'd it go to your wife? Oh
yeah. Natural wine sorry I
apologize listen to this the
largest 3D printed neighborhood
in the US is currently being
built in Austin Texas next time
the Texas sheriff says this
town ain't big enough for the
two of us the outlaw can say
hold on I'll print more This is
interesting. New research found
that Americans get 30 minutes
less exercise than they did 200
years ago.
People in the 1800s also
gargled with gasoline so let's
maybe call it a wash right
anything yeah people in the
1800s led healthier more
energetic lives and made it to
the ripe old age of 28 and
finally I saw that a guy in
Hawaii who got into some
trouble with the law try to
flee the scene in a pretty
unique way watch this on Hawaii
Island police say this man fled
on a stolen lawn mower after
starting a small brush pipe
witnesses took video of the man
riding the stolen push lawn
mower down highway eleven I
think we're gonna test Rick
actually just pushed the lawn
mower and just ran with it. Uh
but he had the last laugh when
he held the weed wacker in the
air and took off like a
helicopter. So long suckers.
Using a name change for a
while. Now, today, Mark
Zuckerberg finally revealed the
new name of Facebook. Here it
is. To reflect who we are and
what we hope to build, I am
proud to announce that starting
today, our company is now meta.
Meta. What? Yeah. Meta. As in
when I joined Facebook, I met a
lot of crazy people.
Yeah, Facebook changed their
name. In response, Spectrum was
like, we used to be time
warrant. People still hate us.
This feels like when there's an
E coli outbreak at a pizza
place and they just change the
name from Sal and Tony's to
Tony and Sal's. Same gross
owners. Yeah. Um companies
often change their name to help
their image and senses up for
grabs. Johnson and Johnson is
now Facebook and Facebook. So,
take it. Meta. Yeah, Meta.
Apparently, they're trying to
win back younger users. Uh they
even release a new ad and it
seems that they're trying a
little too hard to get to you
be the judge. What up fam? You
want a dope social media
network that's so snatched?
Then join Facebook. It's Gucci.
No cap. We're totally buzzing
with Russian memes. And we got
a hell of fire CEO. What the
suck? Facebook, we're not
Chucky, we're the goat. Also,
we're thirsty AF. Yeah, it's
it. I just
What up fam?
Some news from the White House
coming off some of his lowest
approval rating numbers. Today
President Biden left for Europe
and his first stop is in Rome
where he's gonna meet with Pope
Francis. Now however the
Vatican just cancelled the live
broadcast of the two of them
meeting. Not a great sign for
Biden when the pope is like I
can't be seen with you right
now. Meanwhile since Biden is
gonna be out of town for
Halloween. The White House will
not be holding its usual trick
or treating event. Smart smart
move though announced to the
entire country that you're
gonna be out of town on
Halloween. Thank you. How far
do you think I could throw this
egg? You hit the west wing from
here you think? If there's
another toilet paper shortage
you can find it in all the
trees around the White House.
Biden actually wanted to do
trick or treating but Joe
Manchin blocked it cuz he hates
government handouts.
That's right. No Halloween at
the White House. Meanwhile, one
very nervous bird was like,
he's still doing the turkey
pardoning next month, right?
Hi, I'm I'm Giblet by the way.
I'm Wishbone, yeah. In a couple
couple weeks. It's gonna be
like red light green light with
us so
Do you guys see this while
talking to reporters? Senator
Bernie Sanders was interrupted
by a phone call and people are
talking about his loud
ringtone. Listen to that. So
you're not important with this
framework as it's now drafted.
I wanna see it in language. I
wanna see it in in proof. Uh
and again I think it I I you
know. Yeah that's actually
that's actually not an old
timey ringtone. He actually has
a rotary phone in his pocket. I
can only go 60 feet from my
house before the
Then he picked up the phone by
putting a horn in his ear.
Hello. What? Hey, this is cool.
Uh Delta Airlines is launching
a new program that will use
facial recognition for
passengers going through TSA.
It's all part of Delta's
brilliant plan to get people to
take their masks off at the
airport.
Had the same facial recognition
program before you board a
plane on Southwest Airlines.
Check this out.
They don't mess around on
Southwest yo. They don't mess
around.
Some more travel news that this
is real. United Airlines just
announced that next month it
will begin selling many bottles
of hard liquor on flights.
The move is all part of the
company's new slogan. United,
you know we're gonna duct tape
your ****
I just have one more. I just
have one more. Uh hey, I saw
that a a futuristic robot dog
was just spotted walking down
sixth Avenue here in New York
City. Watch this video, yo.
Yeah. Even crazier, there was
another robot walking behind it
with a little plastic bag.
I love how New Yorkers walk by
like nothing was happening.
Okay. The robot was like, I'm a
cybernetic organism sent from
the future to pee on fire
hydrants. They're like oh that
that's normal. And finally this
isn't good. A new study shows
small amounts of plastic are
found in the food from chains
like McDonald's. You can tell
things are bad at McDonald's
today. They changed their names
to McMetta. Happy Halloween
everybody. That's right. This
weekend is Halloween. Halloween
is is gonna be fun this year.
Uh thanks to the cold weather
and COVID. Kids are gonna wear
a coat over their costume and a
mask over their mask. Halloween
really is the best out of all
the holidays where we jam a
candle in a giant squash
Halloween is my favorite I read
that 21% of adults will pretend
not to be home to avoid trick
or treater When the doorbell
rings, all of a sudden, they're
like the family in the quiet
place.
That's right. Halloween is on
Sunday and kids everywhere will
be going door-to-door trick or
treating but before you let
your kids go to town on candy.
It's very important to read the
warning labels that they
provide. I've never even
noticed these but this is this
is take a look at this. For
example, on Circus Peanuts,
they wrote, we're FDA approved
but only as home installation.
Wow. That's on their package.
I've never looked before but
this is apparently. You think
you would have noticed that?
No, I hadn't. Like on Necko
Wavers, they wrote finishing a
whole pack should be the final
challenge in Squid Game. Wow.
They've been making neck of
waivers way before they
invented. They even knew about
this show. Yeah. Up next on
Jolly Ranchers, they wrote, if
the bit of honey didn't take
out your fillings, these will.
I dare read that. I've read
that. Next up on Worthers
Originals. They wrote, if you
eat more than three of these,
you turn into Bernie Sander.
Do you know that? I have no
idea. Careful. And finally on
Red Hots they wrote were
basically a gateway to fireball
whiskey. I mean
Where's the lie? Uh let's get
to the news. Today President
Biden met with Pope Francis at
the Vatican. Uh but when Biden
rang the doorbell the Pope
pretended not to be home.
Actually, this is cute. Biden
and the pope decided to do a
couple's Halloween costume. I
thought that was.
The two of them met privately
for about 90 minutes. Yeah. Of
course Biden's seventy-eight
and the Pope's eighty-four so
the first half hour was just
them sitting down. The last
half hour was them standing up.
After Biden met with the pope
the Vatican released some
photos of the two of them
together. Now we don't know
exactly what they were saying
to each other but we can kinda
guess. I'll I'll show you what
I mean. Look at this photo. Uh
in this photo Biden saying
what's in your hand? And the
pope is saying these are the
keys to the Pope Mobile. Have
it back by 11. No donuts. No
donuts. Next up for this photo.
Biden is saying what are you
doing to change the Catholic
church's image. The Pope is
saying we're gonna change our
name to Meta.
Easy. Easy. Yeah. Totally
changed. And finally for this
photo Biden saying what do you
recommend your holiness? The
Pope's saying the jalapeno
poppers.
Yeah it's a big trip for Biden
cuz tomorrow he's gonna be
attending the annual G 20
summit. Uh all the most
powerful leaders will be there.
Angle Merkel, Emmanuel Macron,
Chris Jenner. The leaders will
be there for two days and some
of them are staying in the same
hotel. It's gonna be a little
weird stepping out of your room
and seeing the president of
Turkey and his boxers looking
for the ice machine. Hey, I
read about a man in Canada who
was arrested after he asked
police officers to help him
break into an ATM. Yeah, he's
arrested for being the most
Canadian person ever. Sorry to
bother you officer. Could you
please help me break into this
bank if it's not too much
trouble, eh? I saw that a
doctor in Boston was fined $6,
000 for missing surgery cuz he
ate his lunch in his car and
then fell asleep. Doctor was
like, I eat lunch and sleep in
my car. Does it sound like I
have six thousand dollars?
Finally, with Halloween coming
up, a recent survey found that
40% of Americans believe in
ghosts. That's crazy. I can't
believe that there's something
that that many Americans agree
on.
That's right. So, if you see
something scary, lifeless, and
pale, it's either a ghost or
Mark Zuckerberg.